en tunisie le parti ennahdha de plus en
plus fragilisée alors que le président
sayyed a prolongé les mesures
exceptionnelles décidées le 25 juillet
dernier depuis un mois querelles
intestines et perte de popularité
rythment le quotidien du parti islamiste
les précisions de notre correspondant à
tunis bassem chab y
dissoudre le bureau exécutif d'ennahdha
telle a été la décision de son président
rached ghannouchi dans la nuit du 23 au
24 août dernier le numéro un du parti
islamiste dont la popularité n'a fait
que décliner ces dernières semaines a
décidé de révoquer tous les membres du
bureau exécutif afin selon lui de
permettre à sa formation politique de se
relancer avec de meilleures bases dans
la déclaration publiée sur le site du
parti rached ghannouchi a appelé ses
collaborateurs limogés à assurer leurs
fonctions jusqu'à la nomination d'un
nouveau bureau une dissolution loin de
faire l'unanimité dans un parti plus que
jamais divisée et fragilisée une
décision qualifiée par certains membres
du bureau exécutif de véritables pas en
arrière censé garantir à ghannouchi son
maintien à la tête du parti alors que le
communiqué publié par ennahdha parle de
dissolution plusieurs députés membres du
bureau exécutif ont révélé qu'il
s'agissait en réalité d'une volonté de
camoufler les nombreuses démissions
survenues le jour même le 23 ou 2021 un
tiers des membres du bureau exécutif
d'ennahda ont présenté leur démission la
décision qui s'en est suivie du
président du mouvement confirme sa
volonté de continuer à monopoliser la
direction du parti et à prendre les
décisions de façon unilatérale
rached ghanouchi n'a pas compris les
messages derrière les événements du 25
juillet
que ce soit ceux liés aux déclarations
du président de la république ou le
soutien de la population à ses mesures
bien décidé à ne rien lâcher et malgré
des soutiens de plus en plus rare que ce
soit dans la population au sein même de
sa famille politique
rached ghannouchi a déclaré vouloir
former un nouveau bureau exécutif dans
les plus brefs délais tout en ajoutant
que cette décision n'avait rien à voir
avec celle du président saleh de
prolonger les mesures exceptionnelles
adoptées le 25 juillet dernier